Okay, here are my answers. As you can see basically, you know, mem
cache got's the hash table and dictionaries in Python are hash tables as
well. The semantics line up really nicely. So all of these functions are
very simple. Set cache key to value. No problem return true. To get,
we actually can use the get function that's built in the Python dictionaries,
which is basically says get key. And if the key is not there,
it will return none. If we've typed something like this, this would raise
an exception. If, if the key isn't in the cache, Python would complain.
And the get function is used to avoid that problem. Deleting a key
in the cache. So, first of all what we would do is, if the
key is in the cache, then delete it. And this is the Python
syntax for deleting something from a dictionary.
Another way of doing this would be,
to use the pop function. Which is built in the Python and what
basi, basically this says is, find the key in, in the dictionary. And if
it's there, return it, otherwise return false. And if you don't have this false,
this will raise an exception. I find this approach to be a little bit
more readable, however. So which is why I did it that way.
And of course flushing a cache is easy. You just call clear
on the dictionary. And let's give all these a run real quick
to see if they work. I'm going to go down to my test little
test harness here. And uncomment all these operations and then we'll give
this a run. And we can see that things work. We set
x to 1. And we get back true, which is what we
expected, we get x. And we can see that the value is one.
We get y. The value is none, because y is not in the
cache. And then we delete x and then try to get it. And
we see that x is now none. Okay. So our basic cache is
working. Good job on that. And let's move on to some more advanced mem-cache.